hello English learners from all over the
world Chad here with another very cool
English lesson based on a really funny
scene from friends one of the best TV
shows for learning English so to really
make the most out of this learning
experience download the power lesson
there you're going to see that we break
down and explain all the most important
vocabulary expressions slang also the
pronunciation or the connected speech
and the cultural references that stuff
that doesn't translate very well
so this is a really funny scene it's
based on Thanksgiving you may see Joey
Tribbiani eat a whole turkey too so sit
back relax
prepare yourself this learning
experience and enjoy the scene from
friends all yet
[Music]
okay also just so you know I'm not gonna
make a turkey this year what well Phoebe
doesn't eat turkey baby turkeys are
beautiful intelligent animals no they're
not they're ugly and stupid and
delicious
I find that means that much to you but
just there's gonna be a ton left over I
know them all
I promise I will finish that turkey hi
you're telling me you can eat almost an
entire Turkey in one sitting that's
right cuz I'm a Tribbiani this is what
we do
hey what are you doing you gotta save
room you've got almost an entire Turkey
to eat let me explain you how the human
body works that's it
even if nobody helps me I can eat that
no problem at least give me a challenge
this is Chandler's chicken this is the
turkey you are my Everest what I just I
just got to change my pants what was I
thinking jeans have no give all right
where's that Turkey
Joey
those are my maternity pants no no these
are my Thanksgiving pants
well Joey we're all we're all very proud
of you yes I believe we can expect a
call from the president any moment now
you got that is that pie yeah you want
some uh just cut me a little sliver a
little bigger I'm bigger what are you
afraid you're gonna run out got me a
real pig I'm not gonna make a turkey
this year I'm not gonna make a turkey
I'm not gonna make a turkey I'm not
gonna make a turkey this year there's
gonna be a ton left over it's gonna be a
ton it's gonna be a ton it's gonna be a
ton left over what are you doing what
are you doing what are you doing what
are you doing you gotta save room you've
gotta save room you gotta save room you
gotta save room let me explain you have
me explain you have me explain you have
me explain you have at least give me a
challenge at least give me a challenge
please give me a challenge at least give
me a challenge
I just gotta change my pants
I just gotta change my pants I just
gotta change my pants I just got to
change my pants what was I thinking
like thank you like thank you like thank
you
hey we got that oh we got there we got
there where you got that
just so you know that means that much to
you there's gonna be a ton left over
you're telling me be in one sitting
[Music]
that's it
jeans have no get up this cut me a
little sliver what are you afraid you
gotta run up those are my maternity
pants no no these are my Thanksgiving
pants yes I believe we can expect a call
from the president any moment now you
are my Everest okay also just so you
know I'm not gonna make a turkey this
year what well Phoebe doesn't eat turkey
baby turkeys are beautiful intelligent
animals no they're not they're ugly and
stupid and delicious
I find that means that much to you but
just there's gonna be a ton leftover no
no they won't I promise I will finish
that turkey I you're telling me you can
eat almost an entire Turkey in one
sitting that's right
cuz I'm a Tribbiani
this is what we do hey what are you
doing
you gotta save room you've got almost an
entire Turkey to eat let me explain you
how the human body works
that's it even if nobody helps me I can
eat that no problem at least give me a
challenge this is Chandler's chicken
this is the turkey
you are my Everest what I just I just
got to change my pants what was I
thinking jeans have no give all right
where's that Turkey
geli those are my maternity pants no no
these are my Thanksgiving pants Joey
we're all we're all very proud of you
yes I believe we can expect a call from
the president any moment now you got
that is that pine yeah you want some uh
just cut me a little sliver a little
bigger I'm bigger what are you afraid
you're gonna run out got me a real big
[Music]